working metal and welding pipes are
skills that require regular practice
before they become second nature general
Habib hun a migrant from Guinea and
Salim atiek from Algeria have just
started apprenticeships in two years
time they could be fully qualified
heating installers that's just one of
many occupations that have thousands of
vacancies throughout Germany work is
very good for me I like this work and I
hope I'll find a job doing it okay
Hino Duisburg crafts and trades training
centre has decided to offer
apprenticeships to 17 migrants none of
them is certain they'll be allowed to
remain in Germany but the instructors
have decided they won't be put off by
bureaucracy
don't bring any certificates with them
if you flee across the Mediterranean the
island of Lampa dues is well known I
think they probably have everything they
need in their heads but no certificates
and that's why I think most of them know
some practical trade basics but aren't
qualified but that's no problem we show
them here Jihad my has just begun his
training it involves three and a half
years in a German company plus classroom
instruction my arrived with his parents
from Syria three years ago he has a
residence permit something many others
can only hope for but he still finds it
hard to master the technical terms of
his new trade sometimes they want
something and I fetched them something
totally different that's difficult and I
have to say I didn't have much to do
with practical trades in Syria I was a
student and here I have to use my hands
then there's the language barrier but
jihad Maya's new employer is very happy
with him even if he has to lend a hand
with my training records
jihad my is getting a great deal of
support now I thought this field of
drifting I think that with many migrants
what we're really looking at is a
massive potential of young willing
well-trained people give it one I think
especially with migrants that talents
not being properly cultivated yet as a
company you could think of taking that
extra step saying okay I'll take someone
on some companies are still hesitant
about that but I don't think they need
to be be definite about so if that's
money any happen was so jihad my now has
three years training ahead after his
exams he wants to train as a master
craftsman then he'll be qualified to
train others